This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Many of us like to think that we're not affected by pure pressure. Come on! It's your problem! Great. We believe we're independent thinkers, that our choices are our own, that our values and preferences are inherent to our personalities, not the whims or wishes of others.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们中的许多人喜欢认为自己不会受到纯粹压力的影响。拜托！这是你自己的问题！太棒了。我们相信自己是独立的思想者，我们的选择是我们自己的，我们的价值观和偏好是我们的个性固有的，而不是心血来潮或别人的愿望。
It turns out, reality is a bit more complicated. Everywhere in life, at work, at school, in a big stadium with thousands of other people, at home in the privacy of our own bedrooms, it turns out our behavior is shaped by the judgment, norms and actions of other people. Sometimes we can feel these influences, but more often than not, they're so subtle, we don't even notice their existence. Today we bring you a favorite episode from 2016 that looks more closely at how these forces act on us. Jonah Berger is a marketing professor at the University of Pennsylvania. He is the author of the book, Invisible Influence, the hidden forces that shape behavior. Jonah, welcome to Hidden Brain.
事实证明，现实要复杂一些。生活中的无处不在，在工作、在学校、在有成千上万人的大体育场里，在自己卧室的隐私中，事实证明我们的行为是由其他人的判断、规范和行动塑造的。有时我们可以感受到这些影响，但更多时候，它们是如此微妙，以至于我们甚至没有注意到它们的存在。今天，我们为您带来 2016 年的一集最受欢迎的节目，该节目更仔细地探讨了这些力量如何对我们起作用。乔纳·伯杰是宾夕法尼亚大学的市场营销教授。他是《无形的影响：塑造行为的隐藏力量》一书的作者。乔纳，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Thanks so much for having me. Companies often pay celebrities to hawk their merchandise, so I often see athletes wearing clothes with a Nike swoosh. Tiffany apparently once paid Anne Hathaway $750,000 to wear its jewelry at the Oscars. But a few years ago, you tell the story of how Apacromy and Fitch made an unusual offer to the stars of Jersey Shore. What was that offer?
非常感谢邀请我。公司经常花钱请名人来兜售他们的商品，所以我经常看到运动员穿着带有耐克钩形标志的衣服。据说蒂芙尼曾向安妮·海瑟薇支付 75 万美元，让她在奥斯卡颁奖典礼上佩戴其珠宝。但在几年前，你讲了一个关于阿Abercrombie and Fitch向《泽西海岸》的明星们提出不寻常提议的故事。那是什么提议？
So you may remember the Jersey Shore, sort of a bunch of early 20s folks, lots of fake Tanner and big muscles. I was in the Jepuzzi and closed just started coming off. So we decided to have a little fun. And one of them was a guy named Mike, the situation's soar and tino. And he was called the situation for his famous abs.
所以你可能还记得《泽西海岸》，这是一群二十出头的人，有很多假晒黑和健美肌肉。我当时正在杰普齐，衣服刚开始脱落。所以我们决定找点乐子。其中一个是一个叫迈克的人，局势的索尔和蒂诺。他因著名的腹肌被称为“局势”。
I mean, you can hate on me all you want to, but what can you possibly say to somebody that looks like Rambo pretty much when he showed off? And Abercrobbing Fitch sent him a letter offering to pay him money. And that by itself is not unusual, right? As you mentioned, product placement is a major thing that companies often use. What was interesting about this letter, though, was they weren't offering to pay him money
我的意思是，你想怎么讨厌我都行，但对于一个身材好得像兰博的人，你又能说些什么呢？Abercrombbing Fitch给信他写了一封信，表示愿意付钱给他。这本身并不奇怪，对吧？正如你所提到的，产品植入是公司经常使用的一项重要策略。然而，这封信有趣的地方在于，他们并不是付钱让他
to wear their clothes. They were actually paying him not to wear their clothes. And it turns out he wasn't the only Jersey Shore cast member who had a recent run-in with a brand. Another cast member, Snooki, she was the short one you may remember who's been termed as looking like a parking cone because she wore so much orange fake tanner. She got a free handbag in the mail. And obviously again, sending a free handbag makes sense. Brands may want to send it to her because she shows up in People Magazine or in touch and because she's wearing it. Other people might wear
穿他们的衣服。实际上，他们是付钱让他不要穿他们的衣服。事实证明，他并不是最近与某个品牌发生冲突的唯一《泽西海岸》演员。另一个演员斯努基，你可能还记得那个矮个子，因为她用了太多橙色假晒黑霜而被形容为看起来像个停车锥。她在邮件里收到了一个免费手提包。显然，送一个免费的手提包是有道理的。品牌可能想把它送给她，因为她出现在《人物》杂志或《In Touch》杂志上，并且因为她戴着它。其他人可能会戴
the brand. Except she got a Gucci handbag, not from Gucci, but one of their competitors. And so why would a competitor send her a free handbag? Why would Abercrombie and Fitch offer to pay Mike the situation not to wear their clothes? And it turns out, influence is very much like a magnet. We often think about it attracting, doing the same thing as others. But just it often repels us and leads us to the opposite. And the idea here is, well, if Mike the situation is wearing Abercrombie and Fitch, maybe other people aren't going to want to wear it anymore.
这个品牌。除了她收到的古驰手提包，不是来自古驰，而是来自他们的竞争对手之一。那么，为什么竞争对手会送她一个免费的手提包呢？为什么Abercrombie and Fitch会出钱让“局势”迈克不要穿他们的衣服呢？事实证明，影响就像一块磁铁。我们经常认为它会吸引，做和别人一样的事情。但它往往会排斥我们，引领我们走向相反的方向。这里的想法是，如果“局势”迈克穿着Abercrombie and Fitch，也许其他人就不想再穿了。
Or if Snookies hanging on to a Gucci handbag, maybe that'll help their competitors because no one will want to wear Gucci anymore. So we need to understand how social it's attracts, but also how it repels. You and Chip Heath at Stanford University ran a similar experiment some years ago, and this one involved wrist bands.
或者，如果斯努基拿着一个古驰手提包，也许这会对他们的竞争对手有所帮助，因为没有人会想再穿古驰了。因此，我们需要了解社会是如何吸引的，以及它是如何排斥的。几年前，你和斯坦福大学的奇普·希思做过类似的实验，这次涉及的是腕带。
Walk me through what you did and what you found. This is one of my first studies that I ran early on in graduate school. You may remember these yellow live strong wristbands. They were for Lance Armstrong's live strong foundation. And they came out. They were, people were quite interested in them at the beginning.
向我介绍一下你做了什么以及你发现了什么。这是我早年在研究生院进行的第一批研究之一。你可能还记得这些黄色的LiveStrong腕带。它们是为兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的LiveStrong基金会制作的。它们一问世。人们一开始对它们很感兴趣。
And we sold them to a group on campus. So we would knock down doors. We said, hey, we're raising money for cancer awareness. Will you buy one of these wristbands and wear it for a dollar? Most people said, yes, one of these wristbands and wear it for a dollar? Most people said, yes, they were more than happy to wear it. We followed up a week later to see if many people were wearing them. They were.
我们把它们卖给了校园里的一个群体。所以我们会敲门。我们说，嘿，我们正在为癌症意识筹集资金。你会买其中一个腕带并花一美元佩戴它吗？大多数人说，是的，买其中一个腕带并花一美元佩戴它？大多数人说，是的，他们非常乐意戴着它。一周后我们进行了回访，看看是不是有很多人戴着它们。确实有。
So indeed, people were wearing the wristband. And then we did something interesting. We sold them to a dorm next door. And we wanted to see similar to this example of Mike the situation wearing Abercrombie or a snooki-carrying Gucci handbag. How would people feel with other people they didn't want to be associated with
所以确实，人们戴着腕带。然后我们做了一件有趣的事。我们把它们卖给隔壁宿舍。我们想看看，类似于“局势”迈克穿着Abercrombie或斯努基拎着古驰手提包的例子。当他们不想与之交往的人开始戴这些腕带时，人们会有什么感觉
started wearing the bands? And so there's a dorm on Stanford campus, sort of known as the geeky dorm on campus. And basically we went next door and we sold these wristbands to the geeks. And so the question was, what would those original wristband wearers do? The people that like the wristband
开始戴上这些腕带？所以在斯坦福校园里有一个宿舍，在校园里有点被称为极客宿舍。基本上我们走到隔壁，把这些腕带卖给了极客们。所以问题是，那些最初戴腕带的人会怎么做？那些喜欢腕带的人
that were wearing it all the time do once the geeks started wearing it? And sure enough, as soon as the geeks started wearing it, about a third of the people in that initial group stopped wearing it all the time, do once the geeks started wearing it. And sure enough, as soon as the geeks started wearing it, about a third of the people in that initial group stopped wearing it. And they stopped because they didn't want to be associated with the geeks, right? Once those geeky folks were doing it,
一旦极客们开始戴上它，他们就会一直戴着它。果然，一旦极客们开始戴上它，最初那群人里大约三分之一的人就不再一直戴着它了，一旦极客们开始戴上它。果然，一旦极客们开始戴上它，最初那群人里大约三分之一的人就不再戴了。他们停下来是因为他们不想和极客扯上关系，对吧？一旦那些极客在这样做，
they didn't want to do it anymore. So what you're really saying is that one really effective way to get people to buy your brand or buy your product is make sure that the people they despise are buying other brands. Is that what you're saying? A little bit. Yeah, we often think about sort of aspirational identities.
他们就不想再这样做了。所以你真正要说的是，让人们购买你的品牌或产品的真正有效的方法之一，是确保他们鄙视的人正在购买其他品牌。这就是你要表达的意思吗？有一点。是的。我们经常考虑某种抱负身份。
So Abercrombie shows people that we might want to look like in their ads. But we think a lot less about, well, what might people want to avoid? Might people want to avoid doing something if other people are doing it? We did another study with health behavior showing people actually avoided binge drinking in college when we associated with an identity that was undesired for them. And so it's not just about associating things with desired behaviors to get people to do it. It's also about saying, well, how can we
所以阿伯克龙比在他们的广告中向人们展示了我们可能想要成为的样子。但我们很少考虑，人们可能会想要避开什么？如果其他人正在这样做，人们可能想要避免做某事吗？我们用健康行为做了另一项研究，结果表明，当我们把酗酒与他们不想要的身份联系起来时，大学生实际上避免了酗酒。因此，这不仅是将事物与理想的行为联系起来以促使人们去做，还在于说明，我们如何才能
associate undesired behaviors with undesired identities and use that to avoid people doing the wrong thing? One of the interesting things about the entire field of social psychology, and you talk about this at some length in the book, is the idea that people don't see themselves as clearly as they see other people, or they see themselves in their choices differently than the same choices made by other people. And part of that is is the access we have to the reasons that we bought things. When we look around, we see lots of people doing similar things.
将不想要的行为与不想要的身份联系起来，并利用这一点来避免人们做错事？社会心理学整个领域有趣的事情之一——你在书中有相当篇幅地谈到了这一点——就是人们不像看别人那样清楚地看自己，或者他们看待自己及其选择的方式，与别人做出相同选择的方式不同。部分原因是我们了解自己购买东西的原因。当我们环顾四周时，我们看到很多人在做类似的事情。
At the end of the day, we're all pretty similar. Most of us are not like Lady Gaga walking around in a meat dress. Most of us are wearing shorts and T-shirts, jeans and a collared shirt. Dress pretty similarly. We drive similar cars. We buy similar things.
说到底，我们都差不多。我们大多数人不像Lady Gaga那样穿着肉裙四处走红。我们大多数人穿着短裤和T恤、牛仔裤和有领衬衫。穿着相当相似。我们开相似的车。我们买类似的东西。
So indeed, when we look around, we see a lot of people acting similarly. And we see influence and assume it's happening. When we look to ourselves, though, we look to our introspection. We don't just say, well, what did I behave? What did I do? But we look for evidence that there's a reason
所以确实，当我们环顾四周时，我们看到很多人表现得很相似。我们看到了影响，并认为它正在发生。然而，当我们审视自己时，我们依靠的是内省。我们不仅会说，嗯，我的表现如何？我做了什么？而是寻找有原因的证据
that we behave that way. And because when we think about it, well, I don't think I bought that card to fit in. I wasn't sitting there going, God, I really want to keep up with the Joneses. You thought you bought it because of price or you thought you bought it because you liked how it looked.
我们有这样的行为。因为当我们想到它时，嗯，我不认为我买那辆车是为了融入集体。我当时并没有坐在那里想，天哪，我真的很想跟上琼斯一家的步伐。你以为你买它是为了价格，或者你以为你买它是为了你喜欢它的外观。
So you don't think it affected your own behavior. Even though at the end of the day, it actually did. You're trying to story in the book about a friend of yours who's a lawyer, and he has some strong views about younger lawyers, and there be MWs. Yeah, so I was writing this book, and I was talking to a good friend of mine who's from Washington, DC, and they happen to be a lawyer. And I was telling them about social influence and they were lamenting the impact of social influence on their peers.
所以你认为它没有影响你自己的行为。尽管归根结底，它确实产生了影响。你在书中讲过一个故事，关于你的一个律师朋友，他对年轻律师和宝马车有一些强烈的看法。是的，当时我在写这本书，我正在和我的一个好朋友聊天，他来自华盛顿特区，恰好是一名律师。我正在向他们讲述社会影响，而他们却在感叹社会影响对同龄人的影响。
They were saying, God, all DC lawyers are the same. They make it big. They become partner, whatever it is. And they go out and they buy a new BMW. And I said, well, that's interesting. But aren't you a DC lawyer? I said to my friend and you drive a BMW also and he said, oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
他们说，天哪，所有华盛顿特区的律师都是一样的。他们成功了。他们成了合伙人，诸如此类。然后他们出去买了一辆新宝马。我说，嗯，这很有趣。但你不是华盛顿特区的律师吗？我对我的朋友说，你也开宝马，他说，哦，对，对，对。
But they all drive gray ones and I drive a blue one. And I was sitting there going, okay, I guess. But what I love about that story is two things, right? One, again, we see influence, right? My friend could see all the other people driving very similar cars. It's that one that light shown on his own behavior, he couldn't see it.
但他们都开灰色的，我开蓝色的。我坐在那里想，好吧，我猜吧。但我喜欢这个故事的地方有两点，对吧？第一，我们再次看到了影响，对吧？我的朋友可以看到其他所有人开着非常相似的车。正是那束光照在他自己的行为上时，他看不到了。
Then it was invisible. There, the influence was invisible. But second, it wasn't just about doing the same thing. It wasn't just about buying the exact same car, and it wasn't about being completely different. It's about being similar and different at the same time. And so there are many flavors of influence that often invisibly affect our behavior.
那时，影响是隐形的。但第二，这不仅仅是做同样的事情。这不仅仅是买完全相同的车，也不是完全不同。这是在相似的同时又有所不同。因此，有许多种类的影响往往在无形中影响着我们的行为。
One of the interesting ideas you explore is that social influence can have implications for innovation because it suggests that if we are shaped by those around us, then an idea that in some ways is too far ahead or too different from the norms that we see around us might have a difficult time getting adopted. Can you tell me the story of the 1899 invention known as horsey horseless?
你探讨的有趣观点之一是，社会影响可能会对创新产生影响，因为它表明，如果我们被周围的人塑造，那么一个在某种程度上过于超前或与我们周围看到的规范过于不同的想法，可能会很难被采纳。你能给我讲讲 1899 年被称为“无马之马”的发明的故事吗？
This is an amazing story that I came across while doing for research for the book. It turns out that when automobiles came out, it's hard to remember that in today's day and age when we see automobiles all the time. But when they first came out, they were very scary. People had never seen a non-horse driven carriage. Imagine this thing, almost like a ghost, rolling down the street by itself. No horse pulling it, no person pulling it.
这是我在为这本书做研究时偶然发现的一个惊人的故事。事实证明，当汽车问世时，在今天这个我们随时都能看到汽车的时代，这很难让人记住。但当它们刚问世时，它们是非常吓人的。人们从未见过没有马拉的马车。想象一下这个东西，几乎像一个幽灵一样，自己在大街上滚来滚去。没有马拉着它，没有人拉着它。
People in rural areas called it the Devil's Work and band it from from town. And so people were trying to figure, well, how do we get this thing adopted? It obviously saved costs in a certain way. There was a huge amount of manure on the street. So getting rid of horses was good in some ways. They could travel further.
农村地区的人们称之为魔鬼的杰作，并禁止其进入城镇。因此，人们一直在想，嗯，我们如何让这个东西被接受？它在某种程度上显然节省了成本。街上有大量的粪便。所以在某种程度上摆脱马是件好事。他们可以走得更远。
How could they get people to adopt this new innovation? And what's interesting is the challenge wasn't a functional one. It wasn't that the product didn't work. It was a psychological one. The product was fine, but they had to overcome it feeling too different. And indeed, it's a little bit like Goldilocks
他们如何才能让人们接受这种新创新？有趣的是，挑战不是功能上的。并不是说产品不好用。这是一个心理问题。产品本身没问题，但他们必须克服它带来的过于不同的感觉。事实上，这有点像金发女孩
and the three bears, if you think about it. One end is too different. It's something's too different. It's and the three bears if you think about it. One end is two different. It's something's two different. It's scary. We don't want to adopt it. It's too far away. If at the same time something exactly the same as what people are doing, people don't want to adopt it. Why do I need to change my behavior for something that's exactly the same?
和三只熊，如果你仔细想想的话。一端太不同了。有什么东西太不同了。是三只熊，如果你仔细想想的话。一端太不同了。有什么东西太不同了。这很吓人。我们不想接受它。这太遥远了。与此同时，如果有什么东西与人们正在做的事情完全一样，人们就不想接受它。为什么我要为一个完全相同的东西改变我的行为？
But in the middle is just right. It's what might be called optimally distinct, if you will. And so going back to the automobile, this inventor came up with a really interesting idea to solve this problem. He had come up with many innovations, including a desk for students in a sort of a leg cast to help people to recover after injuries. He said, God, if the problem is psychological, I have an idea.
但在中间的才是最合适的。如果你愿意的话，这可以被称为最佳独特性。所以回到汽车上来，这位发明家想出一个非常有趣的主意来解决这个问题。他曾做出过多项创新，包括为学生设计课桌，以及某种石膏固定装置，以帮助人们在受伤后恢复。他说，天哪，如果问题是心理上的，我有一个主意。
So he came out with this innovation called the horsey horseless, which is essentially taking a fake horse head and putting it on the front of an automobile. You look at this thing and you say, why would a fake horse head be anywhere near useful in helping people adopt an automobile? What it did is it made the different feel more familiar, made it feel more similar. It was just a fake horse head, but it made it look like these vehicles that people were used to already. It made horses feel more comfortable and this thing pulled up next to them at the stop sign
于是他推出了这项名为“无马之马”的创新，本质上就是把一个假马头放在汽车的前面。你看着这个东西，你会说，为什么一个假马头会对帮助人们接受汽车有一点点用处呢？它所做的是让不同感觉更熟悉，让它感觉更相似。它只是一个假马头，但它让它看起来像人们已经习惯了的这些车辆。它让马感到更舒适，当这个东西停在他们的停车标志旁边时
or the stop light of the day, if it were. It made people feel more familiar with the difference. And so this idea of optimal distinctivism is really important, not so different. If it's so different, people are scared. They don't want to adopt it. It's scary, it's new, it's, you know, why do I want to do this thing?
或者当时的红绿灯，如果有的话。它让人们对这种差异感到更熟悉。所以这种最佳独特性格化的概念非常重要，不要那么不同。如果差别太大了，人们就会害怕。他们不想接受它。这很吓人，很新鲜，你知道，我为什么要这样做？
Same if it's too similar, but in the middle, and it's just right. In the middle, it's optimally distinct and much more likely to catch on. So as I was reading this section of the book, I started thinking immediately about driverless cars and the concerns and trepidations that many people have about cars
如果太相似也是如此，但在中间，那才是刚刚好。居中的是最佳独特的，并且更有可能流行起来。所以当我读到书中的这一部分时，我立刻开始思考自动驾驶汽车，以及许多人对似乎能自己行驶的汽车的担忧和不安
that seem to drive themselves. I mean, talk about ghosts in the machine. And I was thinking about, people sometimes have these mannequins that sit in the car with them to give people the impression that they're someone in the car with them. So if you're a woman driving through a city street at night and you want to give people the illusion that you're not alone in the car
我的意思是，谈到机器里的幽灵。我想到了，人们有时会让这些人体模型和他们坐在车里，给人们一种车里有人的印象。因此，如果你是一个女人，晚上开车穿过城市街道，你想给别人一种你不是一个人在车里的错觉
and you're maybe less vulnerable to crime, you have this mannequin sitting next to you. And I realized what we should do is take the mannequin and put the mannequin in the driver's seat. And if you did that, that's essentially going to be our version of horsey horse list It's almost like a taxi driver except it's a mannequin. I love that idea You should you should write to Google and Uber and suggest it I think but again, right you think and really correct about it
而且你可能对犯罪的抵抗力更强，你的旁边坐着这个人模。我意识到我们应该做的是把人模放进驾驶座。如果你这样做，那基本上将是我们版本的无马之马。这有点像出租车司机，只不过是个假人。我喜欢这个想法。你应该写信给谷歌和Uber并提出建议。我想，但是再说一次，对吧？你认为并且非常正确的是，
It's not a driver's car doesn't have to look like a car Right, I mean if all it's doing is getting us from point A to point B Why does it have to look like a car? Why does it have to have a steering wheel any of these things? But part of it is not just the function. to point B. Why does it have to look like a car? Why does it have to have steering wheel? Any of these things. But part of it is not just the function. It's the psychology. Does it feel safe? And having someone, even if it's a mannequin sitting in the driver's seat, might make us feel
这不是一辆自动驾驶汽车，它不必看起来像一辆汽车，对吧？我的意思是，如果它所做的一切只是把我们从A点带到B点，为什么它必须看起来像一辆汽车？为什么它必须有方向盘或任何这些东西？但部分原因不仅是功能。到B点。为什么它必须看起来像一辆汽车？为什么它必须有方向盘？任何这些东西。但部分原因不仅仅是功能。还有心理。它感觉安全吗？有一个人，即使是一个坐在驾驶座上的假人，也可能会让我们感到
more comfortable. Coming up, we're going to explore how invisible influence affects the way we think about politics. So the simple idea here is it's often party over policy. Even the same policy, even the same actual thing, we interpret that thing based on who's supporting it. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. We're talking today with the University of Pennsylvania's Jonah Burger. Most of us believe we come to our political views after careful thought and consideration.
更舒适。接下来，我们将探讨无形的影响如何影响我们对政治的看法。所以这里的简单想法是，通常是政党高于政策。即使是相同的政策，甚至是相同的实际事情，我们也会根据谁在支持它来解释事情。请继续关注。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。今天我们与宾夕法尼亚大学的乔纳·伯杰进行了交谈。我们大多数人都相信，我们的政治观点是在经过深思熟虑后形成的。
But there's been a lot of recent social science research that shows that our views are heavily shaped by social context. Even when it comes to our understanding of the facts, we're biased by the thoughts and opinions of those around us. I asked Jonah Berger if this was part of the world of invisible influence. A colleague of mine did a great study a few years ago looking at exactly this. So he gave both liberals and conservatives a number of different policy propositions. So one was about helping disadvantaged people, one was about taxes conservatives a number of different policy propositions. So one was about helping disadvantaged people, one was about taxes, a bunch of different
但最近有很多社会科学研究表明，我们的观点在很大程度上受到社会环境的影响。即使在我们对事实的理解上，我们也会受到周围人的思想和意见的偏见影响。我问乔纳·伯杰这是否是无形影响世界的一部分。几年前，我的一位同事做了一项出色的研究，正好着眼于这一点。因此，他给自由派和保守派提出了许多不同的政策主张。因此，一个是关于帮助弱势群体，一个是关于税收保守派提出了许多不同的政策主张。因此，一个是关于帮助弱势群体，一个是关于税收，还有一堆不同的
policies. And he told them that those policies were either supported by Democrats or Republicans. What he found very much along the lines of what you just mentioned is that when conservatives saw policy, the same policy, if they thought that policy was supported by conservatives, they loved the policy. They thought it was great they supported it you know well even if it was a welfare policy even if it's a generous welfare policy the fact that conservatives seem to like it the fact they were told that other conservatives leaders supported they thought it was great they thought it was
政策。他告诉他们，这些政策要么得到民主党人支持，要么得到共和党人支持。他发现的情况与你刚才提到的非常吻合，当保守派看到一项政策时，同样的政策，如果他们认为该政策得到了保守派的支持，他们就会喜欢这项政策。他们认为这太棒了，他们支持它，你知道，即使这是一项福利政策，即使这是一项慷慨的福利政策，保守派似乎喜欢它的事实，他们被告知其他保守派领导人支持的事实，他们认为这太棒了，他们认为这
terrible though if that same policy that same liberal welfare policy was supported by by liberals all the liberals that are always doing this you know helpful stuff for welfare. I'm totally against it. Same policy, completely different reaction. Liberals did exactly the same thing. When liberals were told that policy was supported by liberals,
如果同样的政策、同样的自由派福利政策得到自由派的支持，他们就会认为这很糟糕，所有那些总是做这种（为福利提供帮助的）事情的自由派。我坚决反对。同样的政策，完全不同的反应。自由派做了完全相同的事情。当自由派被告知该政策得到自由派支持时，
they loved it. When liberals were told conservatives like the policy, they hated it. And so the simple idea here is it's often party over policy. Even the same policy, even the same actual thing, we interpret that thing based on who's supporting it, right? Based on the identity it signals. And this actually happened to me just a few months ago. So, was doing a consulting project with messaging for
他们很喜欢。当自由派被告知保守派喜欢这项政策时，他们讨厌它。因此，这里的简单想法是，通常是党派高于政策。即使是同样的政策，甚至是同样的实际事情，我们也会根据谁在支持它来解释事情，对吧？根据它发出的身份信号。这实际上在几个月前发生在我身上。当时，我正在为一个咨询项目做有关消息传递的工作，
an organization that wanted to help clean energy catch on among conservatives. And clean energy is something that they thought conservatives would support. After all, it saves tax dollars, it reduces the size of government, all things that conservatives should like. Yet, when they surveyed conservatives, they found that conservatives weren't supporting clean energy. And so they dug a little deeper and they found that there was a clear reason why. When they asked conservatives, particularly conservative leaders, why conservative leaders weren't supporting the policy, they said, oh, yeah, clean energy, solar power, wind power, well, isn't that something that Al Gore
该组织希望帮助清洁能源在保守派中流行起来。清洁能源是他们认为保守派会支持的东西。毕竟，它节省了纳税人的钱，减少了政府的规模，所有这些都是保守派应该喜欢的。然而，当他们调查保守派时，他们发现保守派并不支持清洁能源。于是他们深入挖掘，发现了一个明显的原因。当他们问保守派，特别是保守派领袖，为什么保守派领袖不支持该政策时，他们说，哦，是的，清洁能源、太阳能、风能，这难道不是阿尔·戈尔
likes? And if Al Gore likes it, it's probably not for me. And what's so interesting there again is same policy, right? Yet the mere fact that was associated with a prominent liberal like Al Gore made them not want to do it. And so we really need to think about the politics, not just of actual politics, but the politics of identity. What does it mean to engage in a certain behavior? What does it signal about me to do something or not do something? And how can we use that to help people do better things? I mean, there are a lot of political scientists
喜欢的东西吗？如果阿尔·戈尔喜欢它，它可能不适合我。同样有趣的是，同样的政策，对吧？然而，仅仅因为它与阿尔·戈尔这样的杰出自由派联系在一起，就让他们不想这样做了。因此，我们真的需要思考政治，不仅是实际政治，还有身份政治。参与某种行为意味着什么？做某事或不做某事对我的意义是什么？我们如何利用这一点来帮助人们做得更好？我的意思是，有很多政治科学家
who talk about our affiliation with political parties as being very analogous to our support for various sports teams. You know, so I'm a devout fan of a football team, and of course, every year the players on that team change, and it's completely rational to support the team when all the people playing for the team have changed. But there's a famous line from Jerry Seinfeld. What we're really doing is we're rooting for Laundry. And at some level, we're doing that with politics too.
他们谈到我们对政党的归属感时，认为这非常类似于我们对各种运动队的支援。你知道，我是某个足球队的忠实球迷，当然，每年这支球队的球员都会换，当球队里的所有球员都换了的时候，支持这支球队完全是理性的。但杰瑞·宋飞有一句名言。我们真正做的是我们在为洗衣房加油。在某种程度上，我们在政治上也是这么做的。
I mean, what we're really doing is we're rooting for laundry. I love that phrase rooting for laundry. And certainly, you know, that's part of it, right? Part of it is it feels like a team identity. There's also some information there, right? There's this notion that God, if a lot of people that I feel similarly to in the past, it's like this and support this, I'm going to like it and support it too. Right? If I walk by a restaurant and there's a long line out in front,
我的意思是，我们真正做的是我们在为洗衣房加油。我喜欢“为洗衣房加油”这个短语。当然，你知道，这也是其中一部分，对吧？部分原因是它感觉像一个团队身份。那里也有一些信息，对吧？有这样一种观念，天哪，如果过去很多和我有很多共同点的人喜欢并支持这一点，我也会喜欢并支持它。对吧？如果我路过一家餐馆，前面排着长队，
I assume that restaurant must be better. Same thing with politics, right? If the party changes or the party views change, but everyone still thinks it's that same organization that they know and love, sometimes end up following the wrong thing. You know, a few months ago, we cited one of your other studies on Hidden Brain.
我猜那家餐馆一定更好。政治也是如此，对吧？如果政党发生变化或政党观点发生变化，但每个人仍然认为它是他们所知道和喜爱的同一个组织，有时最终会追随错误的事情。你知道，几个月前，我们在《隐藏的大脑》中引用了你的另一项研究。
It had to do with the likelihood of winning basketball games and what the score was at halftime. I have to say, I absolutely love this study. Can you tell us how you came to do the study and what it found? I used to be a soccer coach, and this is where where it actually came from. So I went to a graduate school in undergrad
这与赢得篮球比赛的可能性以及中场休息时的比分有关。我必须说，我非常喜欢这项研究。你能告诉我们你是怎么做这项研究的以及它发现了什么吗？我以前是一名足球教练，而这正是它的来源。所以我去加利福尼亚的斯坦福大学读了本科和研究生
in California at Stanford, loved soccer growing up, and so I decided to become a coach. So I coached AYSO, sort of the little league of soccer. Coach is generous, by the way. I was basically sort of shepherding 15, 12-year-old boys, and trying to stop them from fighting for an hour and a half twice a week. But we'd run drills, and we'd try to get better,
从小就热爱足球，所以我决定成为一名教练。所以我执教AYSO，有点像足球小联盟。顺便说一句，教练这个词用得很宽泛。我基本上是在带领 15、12 岁的男孩，试图阻止他们在每周两次、每次一个半小时的时间里打架。但我们会进行演练，我们会努力做得更好，
and hopefully they learned one or two things along the way. But when it came time to games, I noticed something weird. We were a good team. We weren't the best team out there. We were a good team. But when we were behind it half time, we always seem to figure out a way to win. So if we were down by a goal, we'd win two-one. We'd down two goals even. Sometimes we'd win, you know, we're down two to zero. We'd win three to two. We always figured out a way to pull it out. And other times, if we were tied or we're ahead, we sometimes figured out out a way to lose and so I was just trying to figure out god
希望他们在学习的过程中能学到一两件事。但到了比赛的时候，我注意到了一些奇怪的事情。我们是一支优秀的球队。我们不是那里最好的球队。我们是一支优秀的球队。但当中场休息时我们落后时，我们似乎总能找到赢球的方法。所以如果我们落后一球，我们会以二比一获胜。我们甚至落后两球。有时我们会赢，你知道，我们以零比二落后。我们会以三比二获胜。我们总是能想办法扭转乾坤。而在其他时候，如果我们平局或领先，我们有时会想办法输掉比赛，所以我只是想弄明白，天哪，
You know what am I doing wrong if we can come from behind shouldn't we win all all the time so with a friend of mine great Colleague my name Devin Pope. He's now at the University of Chicago We went out and got tens of thousands of professional basketball games We got a bunch of NCAA games a bunch of NBA games and essentially we looked and said okay How does the score at halftime relate to the score at the end of the game? So how does if a team is ahead or behind at halftime affect whether or not they win or lose?
你知道我在做什么错吗？如果我们能后来居上，难道我们不应该一直赢吗？所以我和我的一个好朋友，一个出色的同事，名叫德文·波普。他现在在芝加哥大学。我们出去获得了数万场职业篮球比赛。我们拿到了很多NCAA比赛，很多NBA比赛，基本上我们看了看，好吧，中场休息时的比分与比赛结束时的比分有什么关系？那么，如果一支球队在中场休息时领先或落后，会如何影响他们是赢是输？
Similar to my youth soccer team, it's hopefully a little more data. And interestingly, by the way, hopefully a little more motivated. If you're an NBA player, you're getting tens of millions of dollars based on your performance. So you might say, OK, if you're a 12-year-old kid, your coach, sort of, could joles you and encouraged you might say, okay, if you're a 12-year-old kid, your coach sort of controls you and encourages you
和我的青年足球队类似，希望数据能多一点。有趣的是，顺便说一句，希望动力能多一点。如果你是一名NBA球员，你的表现能为你带来数千万美元的收入。所以你可能会说，好吧，如果你是一个12岁的孩子，你的教练在某种程度上会诱导你并鼓励你，你可能会说，好吧，如果你是一个12岁的孩子，你的教练在某种程度上会控制你并鼓励你
to play harder, you're more likely to win, but it shouldn't matter for NBA players, right? I mean, NBA players, real big stakes, whether they win or lose, they make more or less money. Of course, it doesn't matter there, right? So that's what we wanted to look at. And so we looked at the data, and similar to soccer, we saw something really interesting,
让你打得更努力，你更有可能获胜，但这对于NBA球员来说应该无关紧要，对吧？我的意思是，NBA球员，真正的重大赌注，无论他们赢还是输，他们赚多赚少。当然，这在那里并不重要，对吧？这就是我们想要研究的。所以我们看了看数据，和足球类似，我们看到了一些非常有趣的东西，
which is there was one place where being behind was actually a good thing. And that was being behind by just a little bit. Teams that were down by one at half time, they weren't more like it'll lose as everyone else would have been if they were behind. They were actually more like it'll win. Teams that were down by one were more like it'll win than teams that were up by one. Even though they were worst teams, down by two points, relative to teams that were up by one, they had to score more to win.
那就是落后其实是一件好事。那就是仅仅落后一点点。中场休息时落后一球的球队，不像其他人落后时那样更有可能输球。他们实际上更有可能赢球。落后一分的球队比领先一分的球队更有可能赢球。尽管他们是较差的球队，落后两分，但相对于领先一分的球队，他们必须进更多的球才能赢。
They came out, they played harder in the second half, and they were more likely to win the game. It turns out that competition can affect motivation, right? How we're doing relative to others matters. Being behind can be motivating, but only if you're behind by a little bit. If you're behind by too much, you give up and you're more likely to quit. I have to tell you, Jonah, that it's been a little more than a decade since I began learning about many of the studies and ideas.
他们出来后，在下半场打得更努力，他们更有可能赢得比赛。事实证明，竞争会影响动力，对吧？我们相对于别人的表现很重要。落后可以成为动力，但前提是你只落后一点点。如果你落后太多，你就会放弃，更有可能退出。我必须告诉你，乔纳，自我开始了解许多研究和想法以来，已经过去十多年了。
And I was really taken aback by many of them when I first came by them, because I think of myself as being a very rational and deliberate and intentional person. And the idea that my own actions or beliefs or judgments were being shaped by these factors that lie. Many cases outside my conscious awareness were sort of a really disturbing idea to me. I have to say what's interesting is that at an intuitive level, it still feels to me that all my decisions and judgments are conscious and intentional and deliberate. I don't feel the effects of social pressure except that you look at the mountain of evidence
当我第一次接触到它们时，我真的被其中的许多吓到了，因为我认为自己是一个非常理性和深思熟虑、有意的个人。而且，我自己的行动、信仰或判断正在被这些因素塑造的想法位于。在许多情况下，超出了我的意识感知，对我来说是一种非常不安的想法。我必须说，有趣的是，在直觉层面，我仍然觉得我所有的决定和判断都是有意识的、有意的和深思熟虑的。除了你看到如山的证据之外，我感觉不到社会压力的影响，
and you have to say, if it's affecting all these other people on the planet, it must be affecting me as well. And I feel like one of the great values of this body of research is it might prompt people to a certain degree of humility of saying, yes, I feel very strongly about the political party I support. I feel very strongly about the sports team I support. I feel very strongly about the sports day I support. I feel very strongly about my beliefs,
你不得不说，如果它影响了地球上的所有其他人，它也一定在影响我。我觉得这项研究的伟大价值之一在于，它可能会促使人们表现出一定程度的谦逊，即：是的，我对我支持的政党有强烈的感情。我对我支持的运动队有强烈的感情。我对我支持的运动日有强烈的感情。我对我的信仰有强烈的感情，
but it's just possible that maybe these beliefs are actually shaped by these other factors. And I might want to be a little humble about the things that I think I know. I'm wondering as you've looked at this body of work, what's been the effect on you personally? What's been the effect on your personal life as you look at all the ways in which human beings are shaped by other people? You know, you read this literature and you do some studies in this literature and you can almost
但这完全是有可能的，也许这些信仰实际上是由这些其他因素塑造的。对于我自以为知道的事情，我可能希望表现得稍微谦虚一点。我想知道，当你审视这部分工作时，它对你个人产生了什么影响？当你审视人类被其他人塑造的所有方式时，它对你的个人生活产生了什么影响？你知道，你阅读了这篇文献，并在这篇文献中做了一些研究，你几乎可以
have an existential crisis. You can say, God, you know, I'm not making any of my own choices. Other people are making all these things for me. Is there no free will? Am I just a mindless or a tamathan? I mean, you know, a great example, and this is something that always struck me. Think about the person that we marry, or the person that we end up being our long-term partner, our relationship partner. We all have this sense that they're perfect for us. We all have this belief in true love, and that we're finding the right person out there that completes us, that the one person who shoe perfectly fits the one person who will make us whole.
经历一次存在主义危机。你可以说，天哪，你知道，我没有做出自己的任何选择。其他人为我做了所有这些事情。难道没有自由意志吗？我只是一个无意识的或……我的意思是，你知道，一个很好的例子，这总是让我印象深刻。想想我们与之结婚的人，或者最终成为我们长期伴侣、恋爱伴侣的人。我们所有人都有这样一种感觉，他们对我们来说是完美的。我们都相信真爱，我们在那里找到了对的人，那个让我们完整的人，那个鞋子完美契合的人，那个让我们完整的人。
And yet, is that right? Is that there's the one person out there and we just have to find them? Are we subtly being influenced by our environment? Did we like them because we saw them more often? And so we got exposed to them more. And so mere exposure leads to liking. Were we influenced by our environment or do we really make our own choice. And for a while, I think personally,
然而，这是真的吗？是不是有那么一个人，我们只需要找到他们？我们是否正在潜移默化地受到环境的影响？我们喜欢他们是因为我们更常见到他们吗？因此我们更多地接触到他们。因此，仅仅接触就会导致喜欢。我们受到了环境的影响，还是我们真的做出了自己的选择。有一段时间，我个人认为，
that was something I struggled with a lot. Think about, well, do we really make our choices? And if we don't make our choices, what does that mean about who we are? And I'm not sure I got to a perfect answer, honestly, but I think where I ended up is, you know, influenced by itself is neither good nor bad. It is just a way of life. It is a thing that helps us make our lives easier.
那是我挣扎了很久的事情。想想，我们真的做出了选择吗？如果我们没有做出选择，这对我们是谁意味着什么？老实说，我不确定我是否得到了完美的答案，但我认为我最终得出结论的是，你知道，影响本身既不好也不坏。这只是一种生活方式。这是一件有助于让我们的生活更轻松的事情。
Imagine if we had to make every choice by ourselves. We couldn't use any information from others. We couldn't figure out what book to read or what movie to see. We moved to a new town. We couldn't figure out what car mechanic to go to without looking at an online review. We had to just figure it out by ourselves. Life would be extremely difficult. And so along the way, we've evolved to take advantage of social information, to use others as heuristic or a shortcut to judgment to make it easier to live faster and easier than it might be otherwise. Does that heuristic always lead us to the right answer? No. There are many cases, some of which we've talked about
想象一下，如果我们必须自己做出每个选择。我们无法使用来自他人的任何信息。我们无法弄清楚该读什么书或看什么电影。我们搬到一个新城镇。如果不看在线评论，我们就无法弄清楚该去找哪个汽车修理工。我们只能自己去搞清楚。生活将极其困难。因此，在此过程中，我们已经进化到利用社会信息，将他人用作判断的启发法或捷径，使其比平时更快、更容易地生活。这种启发法总是能把我们引向正确的答案吗？不。在许多情况下，其中一些是我们讨论过的
where other people lead us to stray. Yet most of the time, influence is a valuable tool. And so I think the more we realize it's effect on us, the more we can spot it in the environment around us, the happier and healthier we can be. We can't fully control it. It's going to be there all the time but the more we understand it, the more we can take advantage of its upsides and avoid its downsides.
其他人在哪里把我们引入歧途。然而，大多数时候，影响力是一个宝贵的工具。因此，我认为我们越是意识到它对我们的影响，我们就能越好地发现它在我们周围环境中的存在，我们就能越快乐、越健康。我们无法完全控制它。它会一直存在，但我们对它了解越多，我们就越能利用它的积极面并避免其消极面。
Jonna Berger, I want to thank you for talking with me today. It's been a pleasure having you on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. This week's episode was produced by Tara Boyer. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, This week's episode was produced by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Parts Shah, Raina Cohen, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarelle and Adity Band LeMoodie. Our unsung hero this week is Dana Farrington. Dana's an editor at NPR and helped us a while back to interview candidates for a new position on our show.
乔纳·伯杰，我想感谢你今天与我交谈。很高兴你能来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。本周的节目由塔拉·博伊尔制作。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特，本周的节目由塔拉·博伊尔制作。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特，
Dana's thoughtful feedback and calm demeanor helped us pick the right person. Thanks Dana. For more hidden brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter. And if you haven't given us a review on your favorite podcasting app, please do so. It really helps others discover the podcast. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
达娜深思熟虑的反馈和冷静的举止帮助我们挑选了合适的人选。谢谢达娜。有关《隐藏的大脑》的更多信息，您可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们。如果您还没有在您最喜欢的播客应用程序上给我们留下评价，请这样做。这确实有助于其他人发现这个播客。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。您好，本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。